NAZMUL IDRIS: Welcome
to this episode of UXD,
where we will show
you three steps
to make your mobile
applications awesome.
In this episode, we're going
to be covering the first step.
I'm your host, Nazmul
Idris, a developer advocate
on the Android team.
And I have a very special
guest with me today.
PATRICK LARVIE:
Thank you, Nazmul.
My name is Patrick Larvie.
I'm a researcher here at Google.
And I have a lot to
say about mobile.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Ha.
You've come to the right show.
The first thing as
a developer that you
need to understand about
delivering a good user
experience, that it's
always about the user
and never about
your application.
So how many times have
you seen applications
demand to be updated?
Demand to be rated?
Demand new forms of payment?
And demand your attention
for a variety of reasons?
Now if you have a valid business
need to push out a new feature
or collect feedback from
users, you especially
need to be mindful
of the demands you're
making on your user's attention.
So Patrick, what
is the right way
to demand attention
from the user?
PATRICK LARVIE: Well, this
is a really good question.
And nothing substitutes
for a good subtle knowledge
about how users are
interacting with your apps.
So if you haven't done
a little user research,
I would suggest
that you go do some
before you tackle the step.
But I think, first
of all there's
a distinction that we
really need to make.
There are times
when you absolutely
need your user's attention.
Maybe you have an update.
Maybe there's something
that's absolutely
critical about continued
use of the app.
You need their attention.
There are other
times when you just
want your user's attention.
It's really important to
distinguish these two.
Because you don't want
to wear out your welcome.
You don't want to be that
app that's constantly
making demands on your user,
whether you need it or you just
want it.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
PATRICK LARVIE: Think about it.
If your app-- it's
just like the story
of the boy who cried wolf.
If you have an app
and you're constantly
alerting your user
about things like,
were you aware of
this new feature?
Are you aware that we
have a new payment option?
Are you aware that we have
some new colors for your fonts?
NAZMUL IDRIS: Right.
PATRICK LARVIE: The time when
you need that user's attention
because there's an
update, there's a mission
critical update, that user
is going to ignore you.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So what are some
things that developers
need to keep in
mind when they're
asking their users
to pay attention?
PATRICK LARVIE:
Well, first of all,
let's share some examples
about wanting versus needing.
And I think the first thing
is it's really important
to imagine that your
app doesn't just
rely on the phone's battery.
It doesn't just rely on
the network connection.
It doesn't just rely
on the computing
capacity of that device.
It also relies on
another finite resource,
which is your user's attention.
Let's say that the app has
just gone through an update.
And that update is
available to be released.
Let's say, in fact, that you
the most awesome pizza ordering
app in the world.
I am a big fan of
that pizza app,
because that delivers the
best pizza every time.
Think about this.
If you have an update,
it's something critical.
Let's say that you're going
to release a new feature that
allows the use of text message
to communicate between driver
and the person ordering
the pizza in order
to make sure that
delivery occurs on time.
But this requires a new
consent from the user
because the user has to say
yes, I give you consent.
I consent to the use of
the text messaging app.
Think about this.
When is the best time to direct
that user to the Play Store
to update that app and
to provide a new consent?
Is it when they're
ordering pizza?
NAZMUL IDRIS: Probably not.
PATRICK LARVIE: Probably not.
The goal here is to turn a
demand-- I must have consent
in order to roll out this new
feature-- into an invitation.
NAZMUL IDRIS: No,
that makes sense.
That makes sense.
So you might want
to provide users
that have older versions
of your application
with a message inside
of the application that
tells them there's a new
version that's coming
and what benefits they're
going to get when they upgrade.
Like in this case,
the SMS feature.
So another thing you might do
is that if you have their email
address, you might
consider sending them
a short targeted message.
And again, only
to folks that are
using the old versions
of your application.
Again, to give them a reason
for why they need to upgrade
and the benefits they're going
to have when they actually
perform the upgrade.
PATRICK LARVIE: That's right.
You want to avoid the situation
where the person discovers
a need for a critical update
at the moment when I'm really,
really hungry and
I want that pizza.
That's not the moment.
Another limited resource
to take into consideration.
As we all know, mobile devices
can only operate for so long
before they need
to be recharged.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
PATRICK LARVIE: Again, we
think of this as a constraint.
But I think app
developers should
think of this as an opportunity.
Because this provides
you with an opportunity
to delight your user.
And it's an opportunity
to think about how
awareness of the
phone's limitations
can be a way that you
can work with your user,
rather than against
your user's device.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
And again, speaking
of finite resources,
battery power is
not the only one.
But there's also
network bandwidth.
There's network availability.
The amount of memory in the
machine, CPU utilization.
And also outside of the
machine, the user's attention.
PATRICK LARVIE: That's right.
I think it's really important to
be aware of the device's state
at moments when this is
critical to your app.
For example, let's say you are
an app developer with the most
awesome cat video app ever.
You know that your user is
queuing up some awesome cat
apps to watch.
But you're also aware that
user's battery is down
to about 20%.
This is actually an opportunity.
It sounds like this is going
to be a disaster for your app,
right?
No.
This is a moment when you
might engage your user in say,
you know, at the current
rate you're going,
this is only going to go
on for about five minutes.
Might we switch to
a lower resolution?
Might we queue this for later?
There are lots of ways
that the app developer can
say, all right, I'm aware of
the limitation of this device.
I'm going to turn this into
an opportunity for my user
to reengage rather than
being the app that's
on when the device crashes.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
And as we know, the
internet was invented
to share cat
pictures and videos.
PATRICK LARVIE: Yes.
NAZMUL IDRIS: So now in addition
to battery, another thing--
actually, while we're
talking about battery.
One of the biggest drains
on batteries is GPS.
And I think it's important
for developers to keep in mind
when they should ask for
high resolution readings that
consume a lot of battery
life versus when they can do
with coarse readings that don't
require a lot of battery life.
So for example, in that
pizza ordering application
you mentioned, it
might be appropriate
at different moments in
time in the user interaction
for that pizza
ordering application
to ask for really
high resolution,
location information
from the GPS.
Which might drain
battery, but it'll
be for a short period of time.
But for 90% of the
time or even longer
when the application
is just sitting,
and you haven't ordered a pizza.
There is absolutely no
reason for that thing
to constantly ask for
high resolution location
updates, which will
actually drain battery.
PATRICK LARVIE: That's
absolutely right.
Again, you don't want to be
the app that users remember
as the one that crashed
their device, as the one that
drained their memory.
And what Nazmul is saying
makes absolute sense.
Nothing irritates
me more than when
I see my GPS turn on for
absolutely no reason when
I have 5% battery left.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
PATRICK LARVIE:
Remember, you want
to look for opportunities
to delight your user.
You also want to look
for opportunities
to avoid the situation where
your app is involved in a crash
or in a critical incident.
Because it doesn't matter if the
user was only watching your cat
video app for five minutes
before their device
turned off because it didn't
have any more battery.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Right.
PATRICK LARVIE:
The user is going
to remember that app
forever as the one that
drained my battery.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah, exactly.
And even if it was, let's say,
that pizza ordering application
that was at fault.
But because the user perceived
that the cat video application
was the one that was running
when the battery went down,
that's all they're
going to associate
with that negative event.
And negative events
stick with us
much more than positive events.
PATRICK LARVIE: That's right.
Here's a slightly different
take on this topic.
There are times--
and this is a want.
There are times when you want
to get feedback from your users
on how they like your app,
or how the app is performing,
or things that they think your
app could do to be better.
Resist the temptation to
ask your user to rate,
share, like, or
otherwise comment
on the app at critical moments.
Let's go back to the
pizza app for a moment.
Let's say that you know
that that user habitually
selects pizzas, orders pizzas,
chooses favorite pizzas,
and has them delivered.
What's the right time,
what's the seducible moment
in the usage life cycle
to reach out to that user?
Is it while he's
ordering the pizza?
Is it while he's waiting for
that pizza to be delivered?
Is it while he's
eating the pizza?
No.
This is, again, an
opportunity to turn
a demand-- you
need good ratings.
You need feedback.
But you want to turn that
demand into an invitation.
You know when that
pizza was delivered.
I would say starting about 60
minutes post-delivery, that
might be a decent time to ask.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So in addition to the three
issues we talked about, here
are some more best practices
for developers to think about
when they're actually
building their applications.
So coming back to
this issue of updates.
Let's say that you have
updated your application,
like that pizza ordering app,
and you more permissions.
But also as you've
updated the new version,
there's some changes you've
made to the back end.
And you need to basically move
users off of the old back end
into the new back end.
So it's critical
in this situation
to actually make sure
everybody has migrated first
before you turn off the old web
services that you have running.
And that is actually something
developers, or some application
developers, don't
take into account,
which leads to a pretty
bad user experience.
So when users of the
older applications
go to actually run
them, they just
stop working, which
is pretty awful.
And so you have to keep in mind
that it takes time for updates
to reach all the users
of your application.
So make sure that
you're checking
to see how many times your old
web services are being used,
and so on, before you actually
decided to turn them off.
So another thing
you might want to do
if it's a really
critical upgrade
and you can't really
wait, consider actually
giving them an
explicit notification.
And this way, at the very
least, when they need it,
they won't be surprised that
it's not working anymore,
because you've
actually done the work
and you've actually
notified them ahead of time
that they do need to
perform this update.
PATRICK LARVIE: And this
is also an important topic
for developers to remember,
because notifications
can be super helpful.
There are lots of opportunities
to inform and to engage
your users through
notifications.
But it's equally
important that you
don't have to turn everything
into a notification.
So let's say you've
done your research.
You know how your
users are engaging
with your pizza delivery app.
And you know how to time that.
There are good ways
and less good ways
to reach out for the rating
or for some feedback.
You know that you've done it.
The users had the pizza, and
the pizza's been delivered.
It's about 60 minutes.
That's the right time
to reach out to them.
That may also be the
right time to give them
other notifications
related to, for example,
changes in payment.
It might be an opportunity
for other kinds
of noncritical-- changes
in payment options, changes
in selection of pizzas.
Other kinds of
noncritical things,
you might consider batching
these intelligently
and delivering them at a time
you know that the user is
in a state of mind to
pay attention to them.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That
makes a lot of sense.
So I guess the most
important thing
is that the timing is critical
and that understanding
the difference between
what is engagement
and what is an interruption.
So like in this situation,
if for example, I
need to rate my pizza,
like how the delivery was.
It's not that the
feature is a bad thing.
I do need that feedback.
But the presentation
and the timing
of when that feature is
surfaced in the user experience
determines whether the user
actually is delighted by it
or is actually is
somewhat annoyed by it.
PATRICK LARVIE: Right.
We can take an example
of a notification that
can be either an interruption
or an opportunity
to engage depending
on its timing.
Pizza app.
Let's say something
fundamental is
changing with that pizza app.
It's going to use text messages
to help locate where I am
and to communicate
with the driver.
This is a fundamental
feature change.
It requires the consent.
If I receive an
email about that,
and I know that before I
go to order my next pizza,
that's an opportunity to
engage your user and say,
hey, I know why you're
asking for consent.
I know that this benefits me.
Awesome.
I can't wait to
order another pizza.
If I find out that I
have to update the app
and provide consent as
I'm ordering a pizza,
that's now an interruption.
Very same notification.
Context determines
whether that's
an interruption or an
invitation to engage.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That
makes perfect sense.
So again, as a developer
then, it's critical for us
to stop blowing fog
horns in the user's face
for every single event
that might happen.
I've seen this in
some applications
where notifications are used
as a way to debug things.
Which is obviously a
very negative thing.
And I've also seen persistent
notifications, for example
in Android, used
to basically notify
the user that an
application is running
or something is connected.
Those are really bad and
they need to go away, right?
PATRICK LARVIE: That's right.
So back to the story about
the little boy who cried wolf.
Or Chicken Little who's telling
you that the sky is falling.
If I see that I have a
persistent notification
from your app, I'm going to
think this app is telling me
the sky is falling.
I'll fall for it once.
Maybe I fall for it twice.
I will not ever
attend to that again.
And the time when you
have something really,
really critical that
you need to tell me,
I'm not going to pay attention.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
PATRICK LARVIE: So batching
them intelligently.
Finding the right moment in
the cycle of product usage
to reach your user when that
user is likely open and able
to react.
These are critical aspects
of mobile user experience.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah.
I think the batching
notifications
is kind of like a
subtle distinction
where let's say that you have
determined there is a good case
to notify user.
For example in Gmail.
I have an email.
I need to know that
But let's say I've
received five emails.
It would get really
annoying if I
would get five individual
notifications for five
different emails from Gmail.
So what Gmail does
is really nice,
which is it actually
consolidates those five
emails into one notification.
And it says, hey you
have five emails waiting.
And it does so for
different accounts.
PATRICK LARVIE: Yeah.
I know that the people watching
this have had this experience.
I order from a service that
offers two-day delivery.
And that service,
which a lot of you use,
tells me at every step of the
way about each of the items.
I don't really want to
know unless, A, there's
a problem, or B, it's
about to arrive at my door.
This is a great
opportunity to batch.
You want to be the
notification-- your app wants
to be the notification that
I receive just before I'm
delighted because
I've opened my package
and I got what I wanted.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
PATRICK LARVIE: I think there's
another opportunity here,
thinking about
batching and timing.
And I like to think of this
as think before you sync.
There's nothing more irritating
to make than when I'm-- again,
I'm on the bus.
I'm usually on my way home.
I've got about 20%
battery on my phone.
And all of a sudden, all
of my apps starts syncing.
I can see the battery declining.
I know that I'm not going to
be able to send another text
message.
Don't be that app.
The opportunity here is to use
the available data, the data
that's available to your app,
to know a little bit about what
your user's patterns
of activity are.
By using what we think of
as attention profiling,
you can change how your
notifications occur
and how certain
kinds of activities
are batched and carried out.
NAZMUL IDRIS: No,
that makes sense.
So now this data, this
attention profiling data,
it can be collected
in a variety of ways.
Like we could actually have
analytics running or actually
pieces of code that are
basically generating
analytics data, that are running
on the device that then send
all this information to the
server where it's stored,
deeper analytics can be run.
And then patterns
can be predicted
that actually notify the
application about how
a user actually
interacts with it.
Now, this data can then
be used to determine
when scheduling
operations should happen
between the application
running on the device
and whatever back end
it's connecting to, right?
Now alternatively,
if developers don't
have such sophisticated
ways to make this happen,
there's a simpler solution.
Which is let's say you have
an RSS reader application.
And you have like hundreds of
feeds that you subscribe to.
It would be appropriate for
that application to ask you
when you first run it, how
often do you want it to update?
Do you want it to happen
for every single change
in your feeds?
Do you want it to happen once a
day, twice a day, once a week,
and so on.
So there's high tech solutions
to this and low tech solutions.
But the important thing is to
set the appropriate expectation
and also determine
like, for example,
what the user's expecting so
that you don't disappoint them.
Even with these constrained
resources that we have.
So now, let's say
that you do collect
a lot of really high quality
attention profiling data.
You can also consider
providing this information
to all the connected
devices that the user has.
So that means that if you
have a signed-in experience,
you can actually take
advantage of the fact
that you know something
about how your user is using
their particular devices or
applications on their device.
And then you can use that
data to drive the experience
on all the devices
they're signed into.
So for example with
signing in with Google,
you can create a pizza
ordering application
that you run on your
phone and on your tablet.
And then depending on how you
use your tablet and your phone,
both those apps get smarter.
So that's something
which is, I think,
a really big opportunity that
developers can take advantage
of.
And these analytics,
the analytics data
that can give you ideas of how
the user uses the device, when
they use it, where they
are when they're using it,
can give you strong
signals about when
you need to sync information.
When you need to
prefetch information.
When you think that you
should queue notifications.
Let's say you are asleep
and if the device knew that,
then perhaps it would not
send you notifications
while you're asleep, right?
PATRICK LARVIE: I'd
appreciate that.
NAZMUL IDRIS: As
soon as you wake up.
Yeah, exactly.
So these kinds of things will
allow you to deliver delight
to users of your application.
So that's all we have time
for in today's episode.
Stay tuned for the
next two, where
we'll give you the
other two steps
in making your
applications awesome.
And thank you so much, Patrick.
PATRICK LARVIE: Thank you, and
thank you for your attention.